[Music]
welcome back to the things disney fans
with a live action remake of tangled
reportedly in the works we're imagining
what dove cameron would look like as
rapunzel
after all she's already got the blonde
hair and green eyes
and the actor is totally up for the part
when a fan tweeted that she'd throw a
tantrum if dove didn't get the lead in
the remake
duff replied same there's even a
petition on change.org to cast dub as
rapunzel
there are so many connections between
the actor and the character too
keep watching to discover all those
little-known links and just picture what
the descendant star would look like as
disney's adventurous
long-haired dreamer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your love is so sweet
so put it on me hey
can we take it higher what do you desire
let me see that fire fire hey
[Music]
[Music]
let me see that fire fire
[Music]
let me see that fire fire
[Music]
what do you desire
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
bye
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
bye
[Music]
wow
[Music]